it is a monday morning good morning to
you at home you see monica's with us
alex we have a friend in the studio i
know hi monica how was your weekend
it was great except for saturday night
sherry we don't have to talk about that
in detroit it's in michigan what the
heck with the weather
we had our jackets out all bundled up i
loved it i thought it was great but
you know what to be honest with the hot
flashes john it was perfect
i you know i'll take it i won't complain
but guys thank you so much i'm glad to
be here today 6 41 and i'm glad you guys
are with us so you probably know him
from pawn stars i'm sure the world knows
this man rick harrison
wheels and deals with uncle collectibles
at his golden silver pawn store
downtown the show has been a smash hit
on the history channel
for nearly 20 seasons 20 seasons rick
harrison my goodness
he is joining us live this morning to
talk about this saturday's pawn stars
poker run hello my friend i haven't
talked to or seen you in a minute how
you doing
i'm doing great you know like looks like
the whole town's opening back up
and uh here soon everything's gonna
supposedly get back to the middle and uh
this is my seventh it's the seventh
annual poker run uh
seven and a half years now we usually
have it in october um
this year we're doing it uh hudley
foundation brett huntley he's the um
he's uh the backup quarterback for uh
the cardinals uh
amazing guy his sister's got epilepsy so
he started this charity years ago
and uh danielle who um used to run the
uh
upload foundation of nevada now
charities just amazing
and uh so we're getting lucky number
seven uh poker run this year and uh
hopefully we're gonna raise a lot of
money a lot of awareness
and help out a lot families i love that
you know what rick and through the years
you know we've watched you guys and i've
interviewed you many times and you guys
have a
big choice i mean you got a lot of
charities to choose from why was this
one so
important for you to jump on board with
in in addition to
you know your friend being you know in
the nfl and stuff but what else
brought you or drew you to it well
i've done epilepsy charities uh for
years and years and years i had epilepsy
when i was a child i know what it's like
to go through
what these kids go they have
basically what happens is you know kid
has a seizure their
emergency room um they'd say your kid's
got epilepsy you need to go
follow this fine and they just just
thrown out on the street they have no
idea what to do
and um that's why i started working on
you know charities that help families
build all this i mean uh
the humbly foundation you get all i mean
when that happens when you go to the
emergency room
and like you know suddenly your life has
changed you know you have a kid that has
a condition
most people have no idea what to do but
you get a hold of the humbly foundation
walk you through the whole crazy journey
you're not gonna blow it at that
they have with epilepsy because you know
you have a ten year old kid finds out he
has uploads
what is he talking to about exactly the
condition that you you know
it's these do so much it makes
you know it's not the end of the world
we'll see there's a million and one
treatments nowadays it's a lot different
than it used to be
and uh the public foundation can help a
family through all that
wonderful i'm so glad you brought this
to us because i had never heard of the
hundley foundation but i knew
something had to connect you with it so
thank you for sharing that personal uh
story with us okay let's talk about the
the ride itself the run itself
if you're a seasoned writer if you're a
novice how do you get involved and then
if you don't want to necessarily ride
how do you donate or just you know be
part of the
the entire event you know the pawn shop
website it's uh
jspawn.com um and there's a link there
to sign up
you can show up there saturday morning
and sign up for it you don't even have
to be on a motorcycle you can do this in
a car
um yeah it's a really fun
you just we go to different locations
you get a different
you know you get a a playing card at
every location
and then at the end of the event who's
got the uh
best hand whoever's got the worst hand
they win prizes
and um uh all the location they have
different things going on
okay it's just a really fun event very
cool all right so
let's talk about the show my friend
what's coming up because y'all always
have
wonderful episodes big names coming
through because everybody comes to vegas
and everybody wants to come to the pawns
shop what's happening
um i have currently having 19 playing
right now
um and uh we're going to start doing
sbc 20 um it gets confusing
i'll be right over that here
no i mean it's a great season i got all
a lot of celebrities
and lots of neat stuff and
it just keeps on going and going and
going all right
well rick thank you so much it's always
a pleasure chatting with you and thank
you you know for being a part of the
community that's a big deal to me
when you live here you make money here
giving back is a big deal and you guys
have done it a lot so we thank you and
appreciate you and good luck
with the run and it's motorcycle
awareness month so that's a perfect
timing
yep so see the pawn shop saturday
morning all right
take care we appreciate it all right hey
folks and don't forget to catch the mlj
show facebook live tonight at seven and
throughout the week at 7 pm i'll be
talking about everything you know to do
with las vegas and the culture plus
news you can use